islam a british doctor working in idlib
syria right now i'm in al-shifar
hospital which is located in idlib city
and funded by one nation on average each
patient that we're treating in this
intensive care unit is costing 500
pounds so many children have died
unnecessarily because we doctors don't
have the drugs
and the equipment needed to save them
with your donation you will enable us to
be able to save lives by the permission
of allah i used to struggle reading the
quran daily before you instructed
instructed me to download this app i
never knew that this app would have such
an impact on people's lives you can go
into the description box click the link
for ios and android and build your habit
with the quran right now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are wearing inshallah if
you guys remember about one or two years
ago i done a video about halima aiden
who was a somali model you know um who
done many shoots for many different
fashion magazines whatever it may be and
she talked about her compromising how
she was made to compromise a hijab and
made to feel like absolute crap
basically and she regretted that now
this video is basically about a sister
um i think it's a yemeni sister uh may
allah bless her inshallah um that
basically she's done a photoshoot for i
think it's a liverpool if i'm not
mistaken if it is a living football club
or something along those lines i'm not
really sure um and basically
the reason i'm doing this video i want
to make some clarification i'm not here
to have a go at her i'm just trying to
give advice to any sister who's in the
industry of modeling because i do know
from what i hear that sisters girls
they're into this whole modern thing
i don't know what it is i don't know
it's they even like maybe brag to each
other like you know i'm doing modern et
cetera i don't know why i don't know why
that's seen as a yardstick of success
but i'm just doing this video just to
give an advice just from the mistakes
sister halima aiden done as well um so
for my dear sister as well here because
um i just saw this randomly on instagram
and this was one of the comments that i
saw uh which is basically one of her
friends you know congratulating and she
was like okay good morning to those on
the other side of the globe and good
afternoon to us and good evening night
if you are on other the other side of
the globe so this morning i woke up to
the most beautiful thing to see on
social media and that is
sister
making huge moves to all my yemenis
yemenite can we all please share her
video and post it everywhere
and be gassed that it's one of our own
doing this
and this my sister's name i am i am
rooting for you and cannot wait to see
you go further and absolutely smash it
okay there's a few things i just want to
touch upon because it's very important
because from this look i understand um
and in in the photo shoot she wasn't
doing anything
i would say impermissible per se yeah
there might be some kind of free mixing
etc but from what i say like obviously
we assume assumed the best and it wasn't
that she was dressed inappropriately or
there was nothing there i'm just i'm
just trying to make this as a bigger
picture i'm not here to
necessarily have a go at her for that
i'm just generally saying let's look at
the bigger picture guys here here is
that and we see this a lot it's not just
with the yemenis it's like somalis the
kurds the turks be it the arabs like
this thing of you know when we see
someone like for example i think it was
idris elba i think it's elba i don't
know his name it was married to somali
and it's like this and and somali
community was celebrating this and it's
like that's a fire if i'm gonna say
that's not mistaken
what is there to celebrate i don't
understand like and the same we would do
in our community if there's somebody
who's doing something and we praise it
based on worldly affairs and i'm
thinking what is there to be gassed
about why do we feel so inferior that we
have to feel as if if night came to me
and i was like oh my gosh oh my gosh
who cares who cares like this goes for
brothers as well who do things where
they're modeling with girls and whatever
et cetera it may be why because it's
nico it's our money why do we get so
fixated and so hyped and gassed about
these uh brands
who cares do you think in the sight of
allah night armani versace louis vuitton
mean anything
why are we doing this we need to ask
ourselves these questions okay are we
doing it so we can gas black yellow look
you see me on louis vuitton oh you see
me in vogue magazine
what the hell is this
once again i am not having to go out the
sister i'm looking at a bigger picture
please i want to make this very clear
i'm just seeing when we look at sister
helena aiden's story look we can read it
for ourselves
my mom asked me to quit modeling a long
time ago i wish i wasn't so defensive
sis was literally the only person who
had the
purest intention for me the advice she
gave me was dean over dunya and her
stance has never ever changed okay this
is somebody who was a model he was he
was a model he was giving his advice so
i'm giving advice to my dear sister
watching this well why you guys have so
much more to offer rather than just your
beauty yeah you have so much more to
offer and not only that when you go to
these industries shaytan has a plan and
allah subhanahu wa says do not follow
the footsteps of shaytan because what
happens is is that it's going to be is
that it's going to come with a simple
mirror just photoshoot for liverpool or
whatever it may be and then from there
what happens is you're gonna go down the
spiral route where sister aidan went
through okay look at this picture with
her jeans on her head she's saying find
your style and she goes but this wasn't
even my style never was why did i allow
them to put jeans on my head when at the
time i had only one skirt and long dress
she's saying jesus is not something i
used to wear
like on my
trousers let alone put it on my hair
yeah and this one she goes look i went
back to my hotel room and just sobbed
after this shot because deep down i knew
this wasn't this wasn't it but i was too
scared to speak up also very common
struggle when you are the first to do
something like what was that hideous
green grass thing on my head yeah
and this one again i had to delete this
off my page because honestly this wasn't
representation this was mockery and i am
so sorry i was too young and naive to
see back then but at the same time i
justified it because look it's a vogue
arabia but wrong is wrong no matter how
hard you can try to convince it this is
from your elder sister sister um from
this sister halima aiden to my dear
sisters whoever is watching who's in the
modeling yeah do not make these mistakes
my dear sisters don't go down this route
wallahi you will regret it and like i
said again this system didn't
necessarily do something
really bad you know except that's free
mixing etc but other than that the point
i'm trying to make is this is a sister
who's in the industry and she's telling
you this industry do not give a damn
about you they are there to take and
take and take that's all they want from
you and if they're going to compromise
your religion if you feel yourself go
into these photo shoots be you a brother
or sister and you start noticing for
yourself
that you are compromising in your deen
in the context of salah time comes
you're even missing salah why because
nike manager said i'm sorry yeah you got
a lot of photoshoot can you do this
prayer after
that is the most dangerous thing ever
can you imagine you are missing your
salah why because you deemed naik to be
like oh my gosh our money how can i say
to the almighty the manager of our our
money you know i need to pray i know
if you feel this inside your heart one
life there should be big alarm bells if
you say no to these big names and not at
the cost of your religion and once again
i'm not seeing the sister compromise of
religion i'm just trying to make a point
here
wallahi turn your back
turn your back ok sambila if the biggest
brand came to me and told me i want to
do this etc like if it was something
permissible i would say okay no problem
it's fine but if i realize it's
something which goes against my religion
and all that i'll say you know what
bye-bye i don't care if they give me a
million pound check our religion our
deen our allah us proving we should be
hyped and gas the way this sister is
being promoted like saying oh for all
the emanations we're presenting hope no
we should be proud of the sister for
observing the hijab you know i've said
it once
and i'll say it again here don't change
yourself change the game if anything i
want the girls to know halima took one
for the team you know i sacrificed my
career so that they could feel
comfortable to speak up in any setting i
should be like you know what this is our
yemeni sister who is wearing the hijab
for the sake of allah that's where we
should bigger up and we should bigger up
further to seeing that her journey with
the hijab or whatever getting close to
allah should be the focus point that she
hopes she gets better at that instead of
saying you know what hopefully you know
when i'm like you know i'm not i'm
rooting for you and cannot wait to see
you go further and absolutely smash it
and this person wrote that i understand
where she's coming from i'm going to go
at them yeah i would say you know what i
hope she smashes it with her dean i hope
she smashes it when it comes to the
connection with allah subhanahu wa and
i'm not saying she's not doing it
anyways what i'm seeing is why don't we
use that when it comes to islam why is
it why do we not look for recognition
with allah that's all i'm saying bro my
sisters and i'll just end uh with a
verse in the quran subhanallah says the
worldly life is nothing but an
illusionary enjoyment
brother and sisters do not be deluded
with this life may allah keep us firm
and focus and allow us to smash it with
our lord and the hereafter inshallah may
allah bless this sister once again i
have really really i'm not here to have
a go at her and i'm not just saying this
because of you know whatever reason i'm
saying it because i didn't necessarily
see you doing anything particularly
wrong uh but yeah please my dear sisters
genuinely need to find your true value
uh with your identity of islam and them
as a muslim woman and the same goes for
the brothers as well until next time
assalamu alaykum